Speaker 1: Welcome to 2022 everybody. Great
to be back, and there is so much to talk about.
It's an election year. The election is getting
going. It's not going to take very long that
I can assure you. We have some good news to
kick the year off with, including specifically
that radical Republican Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor Greene has been banned permanently
from Twitter. We will get to that a little
bit later in the day, but we have to start
with some words of caution. And we have now
heard from three military retired military
generals who are sounding the alarm and saying
in 2024, it's not just a Republican coup that
you have to worry about. You have to worry
about a military coup. One of the reasons
that Trump's coup attempt didn't work was
that he's very incompetent, of course, and
he did not have the military on his side.
Now there's no shortage of support for Trump
in the military, but he didn't have the generals
on his side. And what these three retired
generals are pointing to is the possibility
that that could be different in 2024. It doesn't
necessarily have to be. Trump could be a different
Republican, and they are now saying, you've
got to be careful about this. Very good NPR
article. Retired general warns the U.S. military
could lead a coup after the 2024 election
and it says as the anniversary and anniversary
of the insurrection at the Capitol approaches,
three retired generals are warning that another
insurrection could occur after the 2024 presidential
election and the military could instigate
it. The generals, Paul Eaton, Antonio Taguba
and Steven Anderson, made their case in a
Washington Post op ed quote. In short, we
are chilled to our bones at the thought of
a coup succeeding next time they have. These
are highlights from a conversation you can
listen to, and I encourage you to do so. How
could a coup play out in 2024? The real question
is, does everybody understand who the duly
elected president is? If that is not a clear
cut understanding that can infect the rank
and file or at any level in the U.S. military?
And we saw it when 124 retired generals and
admirals signed a letter contesting the 2020
election. We're concerned about that. We're
interested in seeing mitigating measures applied
to make sure the military is better prepared.
This is a crucial point. We lucked out in
a sense that Trump and his cronies were too
incompetent and poorly organized to pull it
off. And in addition, if it ever got to the
point of actually getting the military involved.
The officer class and the generals in the
military weren't going for it, but there was
this letter signed by retired generals and
high ranking military officials that said
We don't believe the results. What happens
if you see that within the power structures,
structures of the military? Is it likely?
No. I mean, even they say, you know, when
they're asked, how worried are you on a scale
from one to 10? I see it as low probability,
high impact. I hesitate to put a number on
it, but we need to be prepared for it. In
the military. We do a lot of war gaming to
ferret out what might happen. You might have
heard of the Transition Integrity Project
that occurred about six months before the
last election. We had four scenarios. And
what we did not play is a U.S. military compromised.
So we advocate that that particular scenario
be addressed in a future war game held well
in advance of 2024. And that is a very good
idea. The military has a ton of extremism
in it. There are self-study projects done.
We've talked about some of them about extremism
and radicalization in the military. There's
a whole bunch of it right now. It is not common,
prevalent among the top brass. It could change
and imagine if it did. We know that there
are these boogaloo and proud boy types in
uniform talking openly about their involvement
in the Jan. six riots. It appears as though
they're going to be punished. Let's hope that
that happens. There were members of the military
that participated as individuals on January
6th, and we know that this is a sort of feedback
loop when I've gotten emails from members
of the military who say David, sir are on
base. There's one news channel that's ever
on TV, and that channel is Fox News. And so
when we, you know, over the last two months,
I've been making a more concerted effort to
say this isn't just ha ha, look at these morons
in terms of the Jan. six stuff in terms of
the it was stolen by Joe Biden stuff. It's
yes, cartoonishly unhinged, and the world
looks at it and says, How could these idiots
believe this stuff? How, what, what has failed
education, media society? And the answer is
yes, all of the above. Of course, it all has
failed, but that doesn't mean we can just
laugh it off. And I've been taking it significantly
more seriously over the last couple of months.
And this these interviews from these three
retired generals should make all of us say,
we can't just write this off as kooks who
could never get further than they got in 2020.
They could get further. And one of the biggest
components that would make that a plausible
possibility. Would be the military actually
really being on their side, so we're going
to continue talking about it? Worth listening
to the interview or at minimum, reading the
article from NPR will link to it in the description
for the YouTube clip for this story. Folks,
the right has a new meme. I don't know if
mass formations psychosis is completely killing.
Let's go, Brandon. But it is spreading rapidly
on the virus front. We have Omicron rapidly
out competing delta on the mimetic front.
Right wing memes a we quickly have mass formation.
Psychosis, overwhelming let's go brand. And
they can probably coexist. What am I? What
am I talking about? Mass formation psychosis?
Let me set this up for you. There's this guy
called the Robert Malone. Robert Malone is
someone who has for a period of time now been
credited with and taken credit for developing
MRK vaccine technology. Now this is a claim
that has been fact checked quite a bit. It's
a bit of an exaggeration. What the right wingers
want you to believe is that Robert Malone
is the guy who created M RNA vaccination,
and now he's totally against it and thinks
it's terrible and dangerous and wants to destroy
the monster he created and bring all these
different stuff. OK? A more sober analysis,
and you can just Google. A number of different,
very good stories about this is that he was
one of many people over a long period of time
who did research that contributed to the development
of the technology, which of course eventually
can get applied to one thing or another. And
now a couple of the current COVID vaccines
are based on the mirror. OK, you get the idea.
Right? So so that's part number one. The second
part is Robert Malone has now been banned
from Twitter for spreading COVID disinformation.
And this is, of course, bringing out all of
the that's fascism and communism and authoritarianism
and its violation of free speech and all these
different sorts bringing out those people.
It's also bringing out the people who are
of the mindset of the truth, trademark the
truth about COVID vaccines and COVID itself
is being suppressed, it's being covered up,
et cetera, et cetera. So Robert Malone got
himself an appearance on an emergency podcast
with Joe Rogan, and in it, he I don't know
that he coined the term, but he kind of made
a portmanteau of two terms that exist. And
that term is mass formation psychosis. He
is saying that this mob's psychosis plagues
the side of science when it comes to COVID.
And what is incredible? I mean, this clip
has gone giga viral, millions upon millions
of views. When you listen to what he's saying,
it sounds like he's explaining what is plaguing
the American right wing, the COVID deniers,
the vaccine conspiracists, the Trumpers, the
stop, the Steelers, but he's not talking about
that. Let's just get right into the clip,
and then we're going to talk about it.
Speaker 2: Listen really closely from basically
European intellectual inquiry into what the
heck happened in Germany in the 20s and 30s,
you know, very intelligent, highly educated
population, and they went barking mad. And
how did that happen? The answer is mass formation
psychosis. When you have a society that has
become decoupled from each other and has free
floating anxiety in a sense that things don't
make sense. We can't understand it. And then
their attention gets focused by a leader or
series of events, guys.
Speaker 1: He's describing Trumpism. What
we have. I mean, it's do I almost feel like
I'm over it's it's too on the nose. Like,
I feel like if I give any explanation, I'm
over explaining. It sounds like he's describing
the mass psychosis of Trumpism that I've been
talking about for years, but he's not. He's
talking about people who accept the vaccine
science
Speaker 2: on one small point, just like hypnosis.
They literally become hypnotized and can be
led anywhere. And yeah.
Speaker 1: And seventy something million of
them ended up voting for Trump.
Speaker 2: One of the aspects of that phenomena
is the people that they identify as their
leaders, the ones typically that come in and
say, You have this pain and I can solve it
for you. I and I alone, guys.
Speaker 1: He's quoting Trump. He he's quoting
Trump. Here is here. Is Trump literally saying
I alone can fix it.
Speaker 3: I alone can fix it. Or it will
restore law and order
Speaker 1: to our country. Do you guys remember
that it? He's quoting Trump verbatim, but
we're supposed to believe it's the, you know,
I don't want to call it the left because there's
Republicans that accept science and piers
it. I've never seen anything like this.
Speaker 2: OK, I can fix this problem for
you. OK, then they will lead. They will follow
that person through. It doesn't matter whether
they lie to him or whatever.
Speaker 1: That's exactly what happened with
Trump. He lied to them about all of it. I
mean, how does it? They're all on this now.
All the right wingers now. Yeah. Robert Malone
explain what's going on with these leftists,
this mass for me.
Speaker 2: The data are irrelevant. And furthermore,
anybody who questions that narrative right
is to be immediately attacked the other. This
is central to mass formation psychosis, and
this is what has happened. We had all those
conditions. If you remember back before 2019,
everybody was complaining. The world doesn't
make sense, blah blah blah. And we're all
isolated from each other. We're all in our
little tools. We're not connected socially
anymore, except through social media.
Speaker 1: There's something about these types
of tip. Typically, it's it's guys. Where they
talk in a certain way. I mean, where they
do what they're accusing when he talks about
hypnosis, what when you listen to the way
that Bret Weinstein has spoken about vaccines,
he goes, well, the it's spike protein is cytotoxic.
And I am concerned that they have a way of
talking. And Ben Shapiro has it, too, although
it's a different way, very different way of
talking where it almost doesn't matter what
they say now what now they're all talking
about mass formation, psychosis. What is that?
There's a combination. The term mass formation
psychology is a preexisting term, and it just
means like crowd or mob psychology. And they're
just saying he's adding psychosis to it to
say, Well, it's a form of psychosis. It's
a mass, it's a mob psychosis of sorts. What
is incredible about this is that we have to
share this because this is the best description
I've ever heard of the MAGA movement, except
he's not applying it to that. When I listen
to it, I'm thinking, Wow, what a what a perfect
analysis of what has plagued this country
with the MAGA movement for years now. But
he's not talking about that. Like the the
unaware lack of awareness about the irony
is incredible now. Just because you come up
with a name for something doesn't mean it
accurately describes anything. And the truth
is, I've been describing what's going on since
COVID in this way for a long time. You know,
back in January of last year 2021, I did a
segment called the shared psychosis of Trumpism.
I mean, I literally described this, except
he's he's describing it, but not actually
talking about Trumpism. In May of last year,
I did a segment called 54 percent of Republicans
think Trump riots were led by violent left
wing protesters were. I described this as
a group psychosis. That's verbatim the word
that I used. So it's not a new concept, and
it couldn't be more of an instance of projection,
but this is their new meme. Robert Malone
is their new hero, and the new meme is mass
formation psychosis, and they lack the ability
or awareness to realize it applies to them
better than to anybody else. They might point
the finger at. Send me your thoughts. You
can find me on Twitter at Packman. Curious
to hear from you? Remember that even in 2022,
the David Pakman show continues to be sponsored
primarily by viewers and listeners through
the David Pakman Show membership program,
I invite you to sign up at Join Packman dot
com. You can use the coupon code. Wow. 22.
That's and you have to say it that way. Wow.
Twenty two. All one word. All lowercase and
you will get a discount. That is. This type
of thing, they might outlaw this if, depending
on who wins in November, they may outlaw this
type of discount. Sign up at join Packman
dot com. OK, am I ready to tell you how insane
the US COVID numbers are? No, why not? Well,
we don't have the full numbers from the last
few days because of the New Year's holiday.
I can tell you that the numbers have gone
nuclear or nuclear to quote certain people,
OK, you know, former President Bush, but we
don't yet have the full numbers, but it's
looking like real infections, real because
a lot of people don't test at all or, you
know, all that stuff. We may be talking 1.5
to 1.8 million COVID infections a day in the
U.S., U.S.. OK, real number. We will get to
that. The question about this insanely transmissible
Micron variant is what will it do and for
how long? In terms of hospitalization and
death, although if it's this contagious, the
total burden on society is going to go up
because it's so contagious, you're still going
to get hospitalizations, you're still going
to get deaths if it is dramatically less deadly
as a percentage of cases of infections. It
could very quickly accelerate our progress
to the end of the pandemic phase, which will
just go to the endemic phase. One place we
are looking at very closely is South Africa,
because South Africa was we don't say it was
the place it came from, but it was one of
the earliest countries to be very open about
the data of the number of people infected,
et cetera. We now have news from South Africa.
South Africa says it has passed its fourth
wave of cases, meaning they believe that Omicron
is essentially done or ending in South Africa,
and it counts very few added deaths. Now,
if you're saying but David, a lot of things
are different here. We're going to get to
that. We're going to get to that. New York
Times, the South African government said Thursday.
Data suggests the country has passed its Omicron
peak without a major spike in deaths, offering
cautious hope to other countries grappling
with the variant. Some scientists were quick
to forecast the pattern elsewhere, so let's
look at the numbers that we had. Now, as you
can see, if you're watching, you can see this
massive case spike, I mean, going from about
300 cases a day. To 23000 cases a day. OK,
that's that's almost a, you know, a 200 x
increase of 150 or something like that increase
in cases. But their cases are now down something
like what's that? Six over 24, down about
66 percent. But deaths had a very modest spike.
We don't not care about these deaths, they're
still tragic. But when you see that cases
went up, what, 150 to 200 times and deaths
went up from about 30 a day to like 60 a day.
You say that that's pretty notable. That's
pretty notable now. Why might it be different
in the United States or in other countries?
There's a bunch of different reasons. First
of all. During earlier waves, South Africa
had very low levels of vaccination, meaning
that earlier waves sort of burned through
the population, large parts of the population.
The Bayda variant, which was not huge outside
of South Africa, went through there. That
may provide more sort of population protection
to these are questions. It may remember that
Delta different lineage than Macron, not believed
to not believe to provide significant protection
against Macron on Macron is based on an earlier
lineage. It split earlier, so to speak. It's
theorized that the Bayda variant, having burned
through South Africa might make Omicron particularly
less severe in South Africa, and we might
not have that. We don't have that. And it
may be notable in the United States that the
number one so we have to wait and see. Number
two, the South African population is much
younger than the United States. Five percent
of South Africa's population is 65 plus 16
percent of the U.S. population is 65 plus.
That's a very different. So if we have to
guess right now, there's these two competing
stories. It'll be insanely bad in the United
States, or it'll be just like South Africa.
The most likely scenario based on what we
have now because lower rate of hospitalization
is being observed in a lot of different places,
is that it will be worse in the U.S. than
in South Africa. But it won't be nearly as
bad on a on a case rate basis as earlier waves
were. The other thing that's sort of important
to remember is in the UK, even the rising
hospitalization numbers, a ton of the people
hospitalized with COVID are not hospitalized
because of COVID. When you test everyone who
is in the hospital and you have something
so contagious that could be 40 percent asymptomatic,
you're going to find tons of people who have
it and are in the hospital for something else,
they still count. So my view here is still
cautious optimism, and we're going to continue
looking at the numbers. We have a kind of
nice way to start 2020 in a very particular
sense, among a lot of bad news. And that's
that radical right lunatic. Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene has been permanently
banned from Twitter for continuing to spread
COVID disinformation. Now there are people
acting like we'll get to the people saying,
This is fascism. It's very funny. We'll get
to that. People acting like this was on a
whim with no forethought or basis. This was
her fifth strike. There's an article in the
New York Times Twitter permanently suspends
Marjorie Taylor Greene account social media
service says she violated its COVID misinformation
policy. Twitter suspended her account after
she tweeted on Saturday, falsely about, quote,
extremely high amounts of COVID vaccine deaths.
She included a misleading chart that pulled
information from a government data database
of unverified, raw data called Veirs, a decade
old system that relies on self-reported cases
from patients and health care providers. Twitter
said Miss Green had a fifth strike, which
met her account will not be restored. The
company had issued her a fourth strike in
August, when she falsely posted vaccines were
failing. She had a third strike a month before
that when she treated COVID was not dangerous
and vaccines should not be mandated. Her official
congressional account rep M T G, remains active
because tweets from that account didn't violate
the service's rules. So just to go through
it element by element. I'm showing people
the rep MTG account that one has about 400000
followers. She has not posted there since
December 24th, where she posted a Christmas
message of some kind. I'll just play a few
seconds of it and I will warn you. Listening
to her speak is extremely triggering and a
lot of different ways on
Speaker 4: behalf of myself, my family and
staff. I want to wish all Americans and especially
those in the 14th District.
Speaker 1: And I already I mean, OK, we're
done with that. There are some people reacting
to this in ways that don't don't really make
a lot of sense to me. A lot of people are
calling this so. So there's a lot I don't
even know where to start. First, there's people
criticizing and saying that we need regulation.
Twitter shouldn't be allowed to do this. Why
can't businesses have terms of service that
they enforce? And that, I mean, that's just
what it is. There's a lot of confusion from
people who generally say businesses should
be allowed to do whatever they want, as long
as it's not illegal and very few things should
be illegal who are saying businesses shouldn't
be allowed to require vaccines will hold on.
Can they require that you wear a shirt? Yeah.
Can they require that you wear shoes? Yeah.
If you don't like it, can you choose just
not to go there? Yeah. But they can't do vaccines,
OK? It doesn't make sense. That's one hypocrisy.
But then the other one is they're saying there
should be something that the government does
to prevent these businesses from deciding
for themselves what they want to do as long
as it's not illegal. Now there's another aspect
to this, which is people saying this is authoritarian
fascism. Former guest Brian Klaas, he's been
on a couple of times and he was on a few months
ago. He had a really great perspective on
this, which you can find on Twitter. And he
wrote, Whenever Twitter suspends someone for
spreading deadly lies, someone will call it
authoritarianism or fascism. It's the opposite.
It's a free market company making decisions
without government interference or directives.
Fascism is the inverse. Fascism is extreme
state control. And Bryan goes on to say there
are complicated free speech issues around
social media, which we all. I mean, anybody
who's thoughtful agrees with that. But I can
assure you, says Brian, that Twitter couldn't
make its own choices to ban government officials
somewhere like North Korea. They would instantly
be shut down. We don't have fascism here because
Twitter can do this, and at least for now,
the government isn't saying you got to allow
Marjorie Taylor Greene to lie about vaccines
or Trump to do whatever. So let's be consistent.
Is it illegal to do what Twitter is doing?
It is not. Well, then by their definition,
if it's not illegal, it's OK and people can
choose to boycott theirs. Many of you might
remember or know or, you know, whatever that
The David Pakman Show started in the city.
I grew up in Northampton, Massachusetts, and
I still have a lot of friends in Northampton.
And recently there was a hearing held by the
Northampton Board of Health about businesses
requiring vaccines. More and more businesses.
You know, I hear from friends, this business,
that business is requiring vaccines. I have
friends who own businesses in Northampton.
They say we're going to require vaccines of
customers, and they had this hearing via Zoom.
And, you know, people could comment on Facebook
and elsewhere. And you have all these people
making conflicting and different arguments
like you about this is the worst decision
ever. This is this is authoritarian. This
is not this is fascism. This is all these
different things. Break it down element by
element. Is it illegal for a business to require
proof of vaccines? I don't even care about
does it do anything? I've said at this point,
this thing is so contagious that the vaccines
primarily are protecting people from serious
illness, hospitalization and death. It's still
the cat is out of the bag. This thing is clearly
going to burn its way through whether there's
a vaccine requirement at a local restaurant
or not. But is it illegal to require vaccines?
No. OK, so now we're just in the realm of
opinion. You don't like businesses that require
vaccination, then don't go to them. It's really
that simple. Marjorie Taylor Greene knew what
the rules were at this point. She chose to
break them. It's her fault. She should be
banned. That's it. Officials don't get a special
allowance to spread disinformation about a
public health crisis because their elected
officials. She was elected by Georgia Trumpists
to represent them. It doesn't mean that you
get a national platform or global platform
to tell lies that violate the policy of Twitter.
Is Twitter discriminating against people on
the basis of race when they do these things?
No. Are they discriminating on the basis of
national origin? No. If you don't like it,
you don't have to use Twitter. That's fundamentally
what it is, and this really does matter. And
what I mean by that is when Trump was banned
from Twitter, Mango Mousse and Mussolini the
tangerine terror. You guys remember the guy
the amount in general of hate speech went
down. The amount of people weren't then re
amplifying the stuff Trump was putting out
there. So this works and it's legal. If you
don't like it, that's a different story. And
if you want to propose regulation of Twitter
of some kind. I'm glad to discuss it. But
then we have to be able to say we should be
regularly regulating all sorts of different
businesses that right wingers always say let
them do whatever they want, as long as it's
not illegal as of right now. I want to hear
from you guys. We'll post more about this
on our Instagram. You can find us there at
David Pakman show. So we're continuing our
discovery for lack of a better term of who
did what, who knew what, who tried what. In
the lead up to the November of 2020 election
in the period between the November election
and the Jan. six riots and then after the
Jan. six riots to try to cover up what was
done, tried, said and attempted during that
previous period of time. And a lot of the
stuff we're learning, we're learning thanks
to the work of this House Select Committee
investigating the Jan. six riots in the next
segment. We're going to have some incredible
revelations from Republican Republican Congresswoman
Liz Cheney. But before we get to that, we
are now getting a list of documents from the
House Committee. We don't yet or won't have
all of the content of each of these documents.
But what we know so far is, I mean, chilling
and disturbing is probably an understatement.
Listen to this chilling Trump letter calling
for seizure of election material revealed
in log to January 6th probers. The letter
was created a day before Trump discussed naming
conspiracy theorist Sidney Powell, special
counsel, to probe baseless election fraud
claims. The document in question and you can
find this is there's a PDF and I'm putting
it up on the screen. You can find this. This
is publicly available, mixed in with a whole
bunch of other documents which may or may
not be interesting to you. There is an item
called Draft Poultice Letter, meaning a draft
letter from Trump. And it says it is described
as draft letter from Potosi to seize evidence
in the interest of national security for the
2020 elections. Now there are a few interpretations
of what this could be, and they're all absolutely
terrifying. Let's go back to this Huffington
Post article, which outlines a bunch of it.
The log, along with a trove of documents,
was provided last week. They were handed over
by Trump ally Bernie Kerik, former NYPD commissioner
and confidante of Rudy Giuliani. Kerik was
a key adviser to Trump's legal team, trying
to cook up a narrative of fraud in the presidential
election that Joe Biden won. Besides the documents,
Kerik turned over. He also offered a log of
documents he refused to provide, including
the Trump letter. Among the documents withheld
is one described as draft letter from police
to seize evidence in the interest of national
security in the 2020 election. Though Trump
ultimately didn't take action to seize election
materials, such a letter could be a key piece
of information in the investigation into Trump's
strategy to undermine a legitimate election.
Authorities have found no evidence of fraud.
The letter was created Dec. 18. That's the
day before he met with General Flynn and others
to try to figure out what to do. Trump also
discussed naming far right attorney conspiracy
theorist Sidney Powell as special counsel.
He ultimately didn't do that. Flynn had already
suggested Trump could invoke martial law to
seize control of the election. Remember, this
is the guy who wanted to review voter registrations
nationally, right? That's one idea Trump floated.
I believe it was in advance of the midterms.
This is not someone who considers sacred information
related to people's actual voting, and what
it means sees information is not even exactly
clear. But it's extraordinarily authoritarian.
You know, we talked earlier. All of these
right wingers say when Twitter banned Marjorie
Taylor Greene for COVID disinformation, when
Twitter banned Dr. Robert Malone for COVID
disinformation, that's authoritarian fascism.
No, it's not. It's a private business enforcing
terms of service in a completely legal way.
On the other hand, when a sitting president
drafts a letter saying Let's seize election
materials, which could be a mail in ballots,
it could be voting machines. It could be all
sorts of different things. Let's seize it
and try to use it to steal the election, which
was, of course, the goal that in and of itself
deserves an investigation. That is the authoritarian
nightmare that these right wingers say Twitter
is actually doing. When we now understand
the context of all of this, which was trying
to do an insurrection coup. What exactly did
Trump and his legal team plan on doing with
the voting data? Even the guy Trump put in
charge? Remember that whole committee that
you might have forgotten about it because
it found nothing, but I think it was called
the Voter Integrity Commission or committee
or something. He put that guy, Kris Kobach,
the Kansas secretary of State, in charge of
it. It found nothing. Even he wasn't willing
to seize the voter information back during
that period or wasn't willing. Maybe just
realized it wouldn't work. Right? And as I
was reading all of this over the weekend,
I don't know how many of you saw the recent
film. Don't look up with Leonardo DiCaprio
and Jennifer Lawrence and a bunch of other
actors. It feels much more like a documentary
than satire. The more we read about what this
administration was doing towards towards the
very end, the honestly the the most. So there
may be a spoiler here. There may be a spoiler.
There may be a spoiler about the film. Don't
look up. The most unrealistic part of Don't
Look Up was that some people actually changed
their minds once they saw the comet with their
own eyes, Trumpists would have claimed. Even
looking at the comment, you can't believe
that you can only believe what Trump says.
It must be a Soros founded projection that
looks like a comment meant to scare us into
accepting government control or whatever.
I mean, that's how weaponized this disinformation
has become. And as we learn about all of the
things they almost tried, it makes it even
more urgent that we put in safeguards so that
they can't even get this going in 2024. And
we've talked about that earlier. We're going
to talk about it again. 206 marines have been
discharged for refusing the COVID vaccine.
Now you might say a away, but David, don't
they get the hep a vaccine and the happy vaccine
and the flu vaccine and the MMR vaccine and
the meningococcal vaccine and the polio virus
vaccine and the tetanus diphtheria vaccine
and the varicella vaccine? And depending on
where they're deployed, the anthrax vaccine
and the Haemophilus influenza type B vaccine
and the Japanese encephalitis vaccine and
the pneumococcal vaccine and the rabies, smallpox,
typhoid, yellow fever. OK. All right. Yes,
they do. But this is different. This is about
their rights. All right. So the bottom line
is every time we hear they're going to lose
a third of the service. NYPD one third are
saying 34 New York Police Department officers
actually discharged, actually discharged.
And so when I read more than 200 marines removed
for defying COVID mandate, I think this seems
like a good thing. What I mean by that is
when we found out at the end of the day, 34
NYPD officers were removed for not getting
the vaccine. I don't know that those are the
good apples that we actually want in NYPD
anyway. And much the same way, if these are
the two hundred and six that are being removed,
there's something like 18000 marines or something.
No, I'm sorry, 180000 Marines. This represents
0.11 percent of them. I think this is fine.
These don't sound like team player. Marines
report from Axios U.S. Marine Corps said it
removed two hundred and six service members
for refusing the vaccine. Updated numbers
come as DOD has ramped up repercussions for
those defying the vaccine order. The branch
said it had already discharged 103. The big
picture Approximately 94 percent of active
members are fully vaccinated. As of last week,
roughly 98 percent of all active duty forces,
including reserves, have received the vaccine.
Remember that Defense Secretary Lloyd Austin
in August said all troops must get the vaccine,
encouraged service leaders to set up their
own timelines. To date, approximately 3847
requests for religious accommodation over
the vaccine have been made. Zero have been
approved, according to a Marine Corps communication
officer. One note about that. This doesn't
mean everyone else is vaccinated. Some of
those requests, although they haven't been
approved for an exemption, they may still
be in process. So that's where you get. That's
why we're still short of 100 percent. There
are people who have made a request for an
exemption. It has not yet been adjudicated
or even if it has, it has not yet led to a
discharge. And so that's all going to have
to sort of be be sorted out. Service members
can request to opt out of mandatory health
elements on the base of vaccination on the
basis of a health situation, an administrative
reason. I don't know exactly what would count
as that or a religious exemption. Those can
be temporarily granted or permanently granted.
So far from what we're seeing, none of them
have been granted for marines. I read a comment
and I don't I don't know. I mean, this is
it's just a comment from one member of the
U.S. Navy that there are service members who
are looking for a way out and that refusing
a vaccine is a way to get an honorable discharge.
Maybe benefits, maybe benefits. Although we're
hearing conflicting things about benefits
and that this is a way for some people who
are looking to leave anyway to do it while
saving face. That's one opinion from one member
of the U.S. Navy who wrote to me. Take it
for what it is, which is which is simply an
anecdote. But the the big takeaway continues
to be the legality of these requirements is
not in question. The morality can be argued.
The effectiveness is also not in question.
These work and, you know, United Airlines
was a big one where much hubbub was made and
like everybody got vaccinated other than I
think it was 200 people or something like
that. So these requirements do work. There's
a fair debate to be had about in the context
of Comic-Con, where there is only some protection,
some protection from two doses against getting
an asymptomatic infection. What is really
the goal here? Well, the primary goal seems
to be to keep the burden on hospitals down
by preventing people from ending up hospitalized.
But these next four weeks are going to be
wild. The numbers are insane that we are seeing,
and maybe by tomorrow, maybe by Wednesday,
we'll have kind of like the full catch caught
up numbers from the holiday and then we'll
see how things are looking at that point.
All right, I teased this earlier, let's let's
get right to it. There is now a statement
that has been made by Republican Congresswoman
Liz Cheney, who is on the House Select Committee
Committee investigating the Jan. six riots.
She says they have firsthand testimony that
Ivanka Trump, among others. But Ivanka Trump,
the president, the former president's own
daughter, asked Donald Trump, Please do something
to stop these riots on January 6th. And of
course, he did not. And this continues to
kind of flesh out the picture that we are
building about exactly who did what and when
on that day, what were the goals, what were
the intentions, what were the priorities of
different people? And this is just unbelievable.
Liz Cheney. We have firsthand testimony. Ivanka
asked Trump to stop the Jan. six Capitol riot.
The House Select Committee investigating the
riots has received firsthand testimony that
Trump's daughter, Ivanka, twice asked him
to intervene. Trump was watching the riot
unfold on TV while sitting in the dining room
next to the Oval Office at the time. Let's
go right into the clips. This is Liz Cheney
appearing yesterday with George Stephanopoulos
on ABC. It is it's everything we imagined,
guys.
Speaker 3: It's his failure to make that statement
criminal negligence.
Speaker 4: You know, I think that that there
are a number of, as the chairman said, potential
criminal statutes at issue here. But I think
that that there's absolutely no question that
it was a dereliction of duty. And I think
one of the things the committee needs to look
at is we're looking at a legislative purpose
is whether we need enhanced penalties for
that kind of dereliction of duty.
Speaker 1: Now I want to be real. There's
a reason she's saying this, and this goes
back to what we talked about last week. Officially,
a congressional committees main purpose can't
be to figure out if someone committed a crime.
And Trump has tried to stop the investigation
by saying they're primarily just looking to
see if I committed a crime. Liz Cheney is
saying exactly what she has to say now, whether
it's true, or maybe they are primarily looking
at whether Trump committed a crime. But at
least what has to be said is our interest
is as lawmakers are there laws we need to
pass to prevent this from happening again
if we happen to come across crimes that were
committed in. So figuring that out, then we
can refer those crimes. There's if you saw
that segment last week, you understand the
legal relevance of that, but let's continue.
Speaker 4: But but I think it's also important
for the American people to understand how
dangerous Donald Trump was. We know as he
was sitting there in the dining room next
to the Oval Office, members of his staff were
pleading with him to go on television to tell
people to stop. We know Leader McCarthy was
pleading with him to do that. We know members
of his family, we know his daughter. We have
firsthand testimony that his daughter, Ivanka,
went in at least twice to ask him to please
stop this violence. Any man who would not
do so, any man who would provoke a violent
assault on the Capitol to stop the counting
of electoral votes. Any man who would watch
television as police officers were being beaten
as as his supporters were invading the capital
of the United States is clearly unfit for
future office. Clearly can never be anywhere
near the Oval Office ever again.
Speaker 1: So this was a very interesting
and wide ranging interview. Let let's go to
another segment here where the topic is again.
At any point, Trump could have put a stop
to this any point, and he did not.
Speaker 3: We're joined now by the vice chair
of the committee, Congresswoman Liz Cheney.
Congresswoman Cheney, thank you for joining
us again this morning. Happy New Year to you.
Know you were alarmed by this from the very
start, from the moments to the first moments
on January six when this started to unfold,
you've cut a lonely path in your party. Have
you been surprised by anything you found over
the last year?
Speaker 4: Well, I've certainly been surprised
by many things. I think that in the piece
that you played by Jon Karl just a few moments
ago, he touched on the fact that that we know
now we are learning much more about what former
President Trump was doing while the violent
assault was underway. The committee has firsthand
testimony now that he was sitting in the dining
room next to the Oval Office, watching the
attack on television as as the assault on
the Capitol occurred. We know as you, you
know well that the briefing room at the White
House is just a mere few steps from the Oval
Office. The president could have at any moment
walked those very few steps into the briefing
room, gone on live television and told his
supporters who were assaulting the Capitol
to stop. He could have told them to stand
down. He could have told them to go home.
And he failed to do so. It's hard to imagine
a more significant and more serious dereliction
of duty.
Speaker 1: It's funny to say he failed because
I mean, he didn't. He chose not to do it.
Failed almost didn't suggests he wasn't able,
but he chose not to. And two thirds of the
country and a lot of the world asked the exact
same questions Liz Cheney is asking here,
which is why? Why not do it? And one last
segment here and again, this is this is Liz
Cheney. She's she's. But all power to her.
She's saying we have to be loyal here to the
country, not to Trump, and this isn't good
for the Republican Party. Liz Cheney is a
right wing Republican with whom I disagree
on just about everything she voted with Trump,
something like 93 percent of the time. But
on this particular issue, she is correct
Speaker 3: here about a stalwart Republican
as I've ever met. You come from a long line
of Republicans as well. Of course, your father
served in the White House, your mother served
in administrations as well. How do you explain,
given your belief, your views in your background,
why a majority of Republicans today would
reelect Donald Trump?
Speaker 4: Look, I think that we're in a situation
as a nation where I certainly have very strong
disagreements with policies of the Biden administration.
I think that the policies that Vice President
and President Biden has adopted are the wrong
ones for this country. I think we need conservative,
principled leadership, but the Republican
Party has to make a choice. We can either
be loyal to our constitution or loyal to Donald
Trump, but we cannot be both, and the nation
needs a Republican party that is based on
substance and values and principles. And we've
got to get back to that if we want to get
this nation back on track. But fundamentally,
at the end of the day, we can't be a party
that's based on lies. We've got to be based
on a foundation of truth and fidelity to the
rule of law.
Speaker 1: So listen, she's saying all the
right things, and I applaud her for it. I
do. This is still not someone who's going
to be one of our political allies. But would
we be better off if more Republicans saw Trumpism
and their party and country really as three
different things, and that you can be on the
side of one or two of those without having
to stand by Donald Trump? Of course, we would
be better off. Of course, we would be better
off. So there is Liz Cheney, Ivanka Ivanka
firsthand testimony that Ivanka multiple times
tried to get Trump to do something, and Trump
didn't until hours later said in a video,
It's time to go home. We love you. We know
why you're here. It was stolen, but it's time
to go home. A completely pathetic, pathetic,
almost non reaction to the horrors of January
six and Trump will be doing a press conference
on Thursday, January 6th, the anniversary
of the riots, making some kind of statement.
We don't know what that will be, but we can
be almost certain it's going to be completely
whacked out. The Ron DeSantis story just keeps
getting more and more insane. Let me reset
this for you. The last time up until recently
that Ron DeSantis, the Republican very Trumpian
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis was seen in
public was December 17th. On December 17th,
he showed up at Big Delicious Deli and Bakery
and in Ocala. And he took a picture. This
is from the Big Delicious Deli and bakery
page on Facebook dated December 17th, they
posted, Even the governor loves bagel licious.
So this was the last time he was seen in public
and nearly two weeks went by. Nearly two weeks
went by, and then all of a sudden the DeSantis
people came out and said, Oh, he was with
his wife at her cancer treatment, Ron DeSantis.
His wife is being treated for breast cancer,
and our thoughts, of course, are with her,
and we hope that the treatment goes well.
But that is the explanation for why he was
missing for two weeks didn't really make sense
because apparently that was only on December
29th that he was with her. It then got even
weirder because on December 30th, the Ron
DeSantis official Twitter account posted the
very same picture of DeSantis at the Big Delicious
as if it was that day had some great bagels
from bagel licious in Ocala stopped by if
you're in the area. So understand that it's
very weird. This is the last public picture
of DeSantis anywhere. We know the picture
is from December 17th because Bagel Licious
posted it on December 17th. And then on the
30th, after tons of people saying, Where is
this guy? Colbert is exploding. It's complete
and total chaos. He's M.I.A. He says, No,
look here. I'm out in public, but they post
a picture that is 13, almost 14 days old.
OK, so that's all really, really weird. But
then this is just the worst part of it. And
this is this is just sad. I don't know how
else to say it. This is just sad. There is
now video of Ron DeSantis at a huge concert
on New Year's Eve. With his wife who has cancer
unmasked. Everybody should assess risk for
themselves, of course, you know, your wife
has cancer. We have an insanely contagious
variant. Florida is setting case records every
single day and you go to a massive event without
masks. I mean, what are what? What are you
doing that this is dangerous to her? Take
a look at this.
Speaker 3: And so in Florida, you can mark
it down. We will not let anyone shut you down.
Yeah. And we are going to make sure that our
rights are respected and that's what we've
done, and that's what we'll continue to do,
so I hope you all have a very, very good 2020
too. I think there's going to be a lot of
good things on the horizon and we're looking
forward to being able to do a lot for the
state. Looking forward for my wife to beat
breast cancer, which is going to happen. And
so thank you and keep fighting.
Speaker 1: All right, so you get it, I mean,
listen, we all hope that she beats breast
cancer, bringing her in the middle of peak
COVID unmasked to a huge event where we have
a prevalence where by some estimates, 12 to
18 percent of the country currently has COVID
seems incredibly unwise. But just a very strange
story missing for almost two weeks says, Well,
I'm missing because I was with my wife at
cancer treatment. Except when you look, that
was only on the 29th post a picture from two
weeks earlier saying, Hey, here I am in public
and then you show up unmasked at this. Everything
about this guy disgusts me, and that certainly
doesn't change. With this latest episode,
we have a voicemail number. That number is
two one nine two. David P. Here's a really
instructive question from a viewer Take a
look at this.
Speaker 5: Yeah, David, you describe yourself
as a left winger, right? But seems like you're
a pretty big supporter of capitalism. How
do you reconcile that?
Speaker 1: Yeah. Well, listen, this this goes
to some significant confusion. Most left wingers
are not socialists. This is just it's an empirical
reality. Most, many left wingers like me support
socialization of some elements of society
and the economy. I want to take health care
outside of the capitalist system. I want to
take education outside of that. There are
arguments for with some aspects of housing,
but not all taking it outside of just supply
and demand and markets. But most left wingers
are not actually socialists. Even in countries
like my birth country of Argentina with big
socialist traditions, most of the left wingers
are not actually socialists, so there's no
conflict. I'm a social Democrat in the style.
Of some blend of northern European countries,
I support a much, much more regulated and
controlled version of capitalism whose main
priority is let's use the fruits of that regulated
capitalism to set a much higher floor for
everybody, for the betterment of all. Let's
also set some kind of ceiling above which
we really are collecting a lot of taxes for
the betterment of society. It's called social
democracy, but I don't need a I'm fine with
markets dictating resource allocation for
consumer electronics, vehicles, products of
different kinds. I'm okay with that. I think
it's OK. I think if you build something and
it's a company and it's yours and you built
it, I don't think that should be taken away
from you. However, we recognize that you built
it based on utility infrastructure established
by the government and through track taxation
protection and for intellectual property established
by the government, presumably with employees,
many of whom went to public schools, which
is paid for but through tax, right? When we
recognize, well, yet you, you organized the
structure and you built it, and so you do
deserve many of the fruits of that labor.
It was also built on the backs of all sorts
of government infrastructure and tax dollars,
et cetera, et cetera. So that's why we have
to cycle back a portion of it into the betterment
of society. That's fundamentally social democracy.
It is a left wing perspective. I would argue
it's the most successful, most successful
version of progressive ideology globally over
the last hundred and fifty years. OK, so that's
my perspective. We've got a great bonus show
for you today. Absolutely insane travel chaos.
And it's not just an causing it. We will talk
about Hillary Clinton's interesting 2024 prediction.
We'll talk about how on earth new schools
reopen with Macron spreading so wildly and
much more. All of those stories on today's
bonus show. Sign up at Join Packman dot com
and you can use the coupon code. Wow. 22.
And when you type it in, you have to. You
have to say, Wow. 22. It saves you big. You
get access to the bonus show. You joined the
ranks of membership for what will be a really
important election year. I'll see you then.